thank you
[Music]
is uh geared towards Bart I thought I
thought you would really like this oh
thank you
so Equinox the famous gym
is Banning new members on January oh I
saw this wait what that's really cool
you got enough money you remember
they're being jerks that's nice yeah so
they will not accept new members on
January 1st a day when most people
commit to jump starting the New Year's
resolutions by heading to the gym yeah
it's like the most popular month or
whatever right yeah gyms are packed in
January they're just like you'll come
January 2nd but dude January 1st we
don't want to sign up a bunch of
[ __ ] I think the whole month of
January right there's yeah they're
saying
um well they're saying they're not
signing anyone up on January 1
specifically but they're saying um and
they're trying to basically lecture
everybody about how January is a
language we don't understand it wants
you to start something when you should
be in the middle of it
and then they're they're saying they're
not signing up new clients because
they're not done without that part the
month is a fantasy delivered to your
door in a pastel colored box
and critics are are saying that you're
they're shaming people who are trying to
build new habits
um shut up and Equinox know what you are
you're a hookup for rich people
um yeah that's the part that I'm like
Jim you're a [ __ ] hookup space for
sugar babies and Rich old guys that want
to get in shape it's technical up with
weights exactly it's like 300 a month
it's technically a country club so I
didn't think that their mission was
really Fitness you know it seems like
they're just trying to up exclusivity
even more yeah yeah because why they
have all these rich Housewives to find
personal trainers to cheat with Loki
Loki you're like we got too many eyes
here so people can't cheat anymore we
got to come out with a sick marketing
you guys ever been in the Equinox before
I I've walked by I've always wanted to
so we had a homie that would like get us
in yeah she like worked what's it like
in there no like people know that you
don't belong there they look at you and
they're like you don't pay Members if
you don't have a matching like Lululemon
or some [ __ ] you're like this guy's not
doesn't belong yeah no it's it's I don't
know it's uh I don't like this it's Posh
it is what it's meant to be which is
like the Rodeo Drive of gyms no for sure
for sure for sure but this this is lame
that they're doing that yeah are you
playing I think it's lamb aren't they a
private company Nick getting done
shouldn't they be able to do whatever
they should I like it I think it's great
it's Planet Fitness where it's a bunch
of truckers that use it for showering
and a bunch of senior citizens that come
true but then everyone else that thinks
they're gonna work out one day they they
get membership because it's like five
bucks a month but they never go and then
they forget about it and they're like I
don't care and then they make bang
that's my favorite gym but I think but
it is pandering to the clients I feel
like that's a really really great thing
because that's how they want it they're
like yeah we don't want the gym to be
packed with a bunch of non-serious
people for the first like week of
January and then be turned off by going
to our own gym yeah okay but if they're
gonna make a bunch of money with each
membership's 300 bucks yeah dude it's a
lot of money that's why I think it's a
good gesture because they're like hey
like it's more important to us that you
current members are comfortable that is
pretty cool because that whole like
January 1st thing like it's become a
meme of itself in the gym culture yeah
it's their way of piggy piggying back
off of that so they could like make a
cool statement and be like is there a
way small talks like in December it's
like it's like oh yeah I gotta get it
now if you guys know next month's gonna
come a little crazy yeah kinda yeah for
real actually what if since their
business model is so different what if
they actually don't see the rush that 24
Hour Fitness Planet Fitness and the
beginner gyms do so they just kind of
ride on this marketing when they're like
well you actually don't get sign ups
anyway during January 1st so let's just
pretend that it's live even better yeah
guys what's going on right so they're
they're saying you can sign up tomorrow
like January yeah but it's a marketing
plan Oh I thought I thought it was the
whole month of January it's just because
I believe some of the memberships are
even a thousand bucks a month
what do they do jack you off you're like
Spa access yeah
there's basic gym access then there's
like you get a permanent Locker then
there's like dry cleaning I think some
of them even have barber shops so it's
330 a month so it's like what which
service you have and then like concierge
and the bot the more baller you are then
you're in this the places where maybe
some of the pro athletes are hanging out
so it's a little country they have good
lotions there too man their lotions
there you know EOS has like upgraded
stuff where you can use like a massage
therapy thing or something they have
massage tables you get massage once a
month or some [ __ ] you have us I do yeah
because it's so close to me and it's all
over it's a gym yeah it's a pretty
popular gym franchise that's been it's
very cheap it's really nice well I only
know about barbell Brigade
yeah I'll work out at barbell Brigade
and then go to EOS to take a shower wait
no showers are barbell no I wish you did
oh you know what's funny though one one
day I saw Justin shower at my place I
was in this I was in the sauna and I
hear this familiar voice and I hear
Justin in a Dem and I was like wire trap
barbell why are you here and they're
like Bobo doesn't have a swimming pool
oh wait are they at the one by Chinatown
is that that's the one I go to
hahaha
with the movie room yeah you could run
in the movie rooms do any of you guys
have any fitness goals for for the New
Year dude I haven't worked out in three
plus months it's the long
so that means any goal you said is good
yeah yeah I want to watch eight minutes
is that on your radar or is that just
physically active like I walked yeah
dude I'm the source I've ever been by
standing 15 hours a day oh for sure like
your legs are achy my belly's strong my
belly's getting bigger but my legs are
strong oh yeah boys that's tight
restaurant legs baby you got the cool
fitness goals trying to get more jacked
trying to look like Bart trying to put
on some weight by jacking my elbow up at
the end of the year so too much jacking
off huh okay I haven't been able to work
out in the New Year dude I feel kind of
like I feel like I do you can't do too
many of these motions honestly I can't
even jack off right now that's all that
stuff did you think of a new technique
so it doesn't affect your elbow as much
I can't you just gotta chain your wrist
like this
oh that's good damn that looks like it
feels so tight
imagine how small Anthony's dick is for
that huh you want to imagine it no I am
imagining if you want to see it your
lips
no to put it on patreon I'll [ __ ]
show you right now let's go you [ __ ]
perfect right now hey go to the back go
to the back and look right at it come
back see a little yellow fever [ __ ] I
have a fetish
I thought it says your race it's getting
hot
the sexual tension is crazy
240 a month go to the steam room
together oh my God it's 300 in some
areas like West Hollywood's like 221
let's go to Barbie house I do like I
like that it's a cool status symbol for
people that are there and they like to
say it it's cool it's kind of wild like
when you oh I got Equinox I Spit on
people I get it I'm like that's dope
where's uh what What's the uh hierarchy
of [ __ ] status for the gym Planet
Fitness is really down here they got
pizza dude Planet Fitness is very bad I
in my opinion because I I was there for
like it's purple I can't work out in
purple
it's the clientele it's like the people
that our members are are like joking
it's like they're just kidding it's like
you literally have like people in
overalls everyone's just doing bits yeah
it's like people are just wearing
whatever they want and like you're not
allowed to dress like you're going to
the gym what yeah because that goes
against the gym intimidation so what do
you wear [ __ ] jeans wait you can't
dress like you're going to the gym
intimidations all over the walls bro you
can't look like you're really athletic
because it's discouraging to people hey
if I crush a bar uh um a barbell in
barbell how do you crush one like I go
yeah and and I drop it on the [ __ ]
ground like from the highest Fitness
yeah yeah is that chill you can do that
you can do that I can scream like it it
depends on where you're at because we
actually have bars and bumper place
that's made to throw in the air so if
you're doing the place that's allowed
then you can do it but then if you're
grabbing like metal plates and just
throwing it where there's like no
padding and stuff I'm just chucking
around someone someone probably escorts
you out but I'm showcasing my strength
to to the females in the area I'm trying
to gym intimidate Oh They'll probably be
like dude that was pretty sick but
you're gonna have to step outside oh but
I'm dominating could you help me over
here actually thank you
it's really like written on the wall no
singlets yeah yeah good I like that rule
I don't like when dudes were [ __ ]
sick because it's intimidating barbells
sell those yeah well you compete in them
yeah these are outfits that's our
basketball jersey have you seen the
stringers the stringers I'm like I don't
care how jacked you are bro you're not
jacked enough if you wear singlets you
might as well just suck don't fit it why
don't you make them why don't you make
overalls that's less gay I would wear
overalls as he's wearing overalls
there it is wow that's called a conflict
episode overall gym intimidating yeah
dude okay so we got Planet Fitness then
we got
24 maybe L.A la
does Bally still exist Anytime Fitness
oh yeah Anytime Fitness like it's like
smaller but a little more private and
then you got like an orange theory at 40
crunch have you guys been to a crunch
I've seen it those are like classes
Pilates Zumba all the way up here what
about dog pound
dog pound is like it's that's like the
one on west side where all the
celebrities going [ __ ] like top they box
and they [ __ ] do lips lifting over
there where's gold
I think Gold's 24. because they got
movie theaters all one they got movie
theaters do they really yeah goals have
the goals in downtown has movie theater
jogging doesn't Arnold Arnold go to
Gold's Fitness Beach still so that gold
is way different than the Gold's chain
yeah that gold is legendary
oh I remember saying that yeah yeah the
mecca bodybuilding all the other ones is
more of a like chain gold it's different
yeah if that one has jacked up equipment
and there's it's dope because it has
jacked up equipment all the other gold
has super nice equipment you can just
whack that they have super nice that's
cool and then it's probably after Gold's
24 LA Fitness that's probably uh Equinox
Equinox is up there and then barbell
Brigade and then Lionheart Jiu Jitsu
Academy where we do private training
it's probably like the top of the
[ __ ] really yeah yeah why you look
bumped out you don't look that excited
and then be Waikiki yeah yeah
you I guarantee you you're gonna have
sore legs than you like be that you
never ever [ __ ] experienced in your
whole entire eight hour shift that gonna
be so it's like a threat you're gonna
wake up every morning and you're like
dude this is crazier than squatting but
then it just squats up or down no squat
you just stay still standing but not if
you go squat is your squat going upwards
I haven't even tested bro he's not that
famous yet I don't even know all I know
is I could stand
and have a posture for a long time a
straight posture or do you just read
Wikipedia all day did I read it all day
yeah
not all day but what did you refer to
Gold's Venice Beach as the mecca of
bodybuilding because that's what's known
as the method literally says it is I
didn't read it it's called The Becca
Wikipedia all day
I'm watching you Juan have you guys
worked out there before yeah yeah it's
dope I haven't there's like it feels
like like you see all these pictures of
all these like guys in the 70s 80s and
you see upcoming bodybuilders and it's
just like and you see you'll see some
Legends walk through too it's dope it's
like the whole being in the scene
this is the Outdoor gym one on the beach
that's what says in Wikipedia everything
he just says I like that one
I'ma start working out again it's all
getting swole together let's go me too
well I've been working out but uh but
I'm I need to upgrade my weights because
I outgrew my 35s because I've been
crushing too much [ __ ] metal dude
you're dropping it at the top of the
city drop it all away yeah shipping it
off shipping my [ __ ] garage before
lowering my property value
by yelling so my wife
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]